good morning good morning everyone I
know many of you but if I've not met you
I'm Ian lessor from gmf here in Brussels
and on behalf of GM F it's really my
pleasure to welcome you this morning to
this well very timely very important
opportunity to hear from Cecilia
malmström European commissioner for
trade on the challenges we face in this
very critical area of transatlantic
relations in as it says in the title
turbulent times madam commissioner
welcome thank you for joining us we've
had the pleasure of having you with us
on occasions before it presses forum in
particular and we're delighted to have
you again
GM F's mission very simply is to
strengthen transatlantic cooperation in
the spirit of the Marshall Plan we're an
American institution as many of you will
know but with deep ties here in Europe
in Brussels we have offices in six other
European capitals
we're non partisan in the American
terminology but we take very seriously
the values and interests that bind
Europe or should bind Europe in the
United States across the Atlantic and I
think you will agree that in these
troubled and troubling times those with
an attachment to this kind of
multilateral open system will have a
task and so one of the tasks is to have
events like this where we can have
discussions about some of the critical
issues not least trade we don't need to
say more about the role of Trade and the
relationship or the role of the
relationship in the global trade but you
know just if we think in a little more
historical terms and reflect on the
ability of a deterioration in trade
relations to jeopardize not just
prosperity but global stability is
something it's sobering so an important
issue there's a lot going on we're
grateful
your presence here in a very busy period
not least you have had concluded an
extraordinary agreement with with Japan
which I'm sure you'll say something
about there are ongoing discussions with
China with Mercosur partners many things
happening on many fronts but not least
you're going to Washington shortly yeah
and anyway you may want to say so say a
little bit about that just to give you a
roadmap to what we're going to do this
morning I know you have limited time but
we're fortunate you will have you with
us for some remarks and then afterwards
we'll open it up for a period to all of
you for some Q&A so commissioner miles
from once again we're delighted to have
you with us to share your thoughts the
floor is yours
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
I am so happy to be here today thank you
for joining thank you to our host the
German Marshall Fund I think you could
not find a more appropriate host for a
discussion such as this one because of
course the German Marshall Fund was
founded as a memorial to the Marshall
Plan assistance it stands as a testament
to friendship between the United States
and Europe the two continents the
generosity of US foreign policy and the
pivotal relationship at the center of
Western success in the Cold War and this
is important not just as a memorial to a
friendship but also as a reminder of
what the world looked like not long ago
many have already forgotten
little by little perspectives have
changed stories has been misremembered
the danger of memories is that they do
not die suddenly they faint and they are
distorted and it is all in our interests
to refresh them constantly modern
liberal Europe was only possible with
the help of the United States and this
was why widely known once but the
generation who built the world as we
know it today is dying out building a
peace
full Democratic Europe was the purpose
behind the Marshall Plan it was part of
a vision a part of a global architecture
that was meant to establish freedom
democracy at the heart of the global
order it stood against the very real
threats of totalitarianism and anarchy
the generation of build disorder had
seen where these paths led straight down
to the trenches they did not want to go
back although not without false that
plan was successful it was a victory of
Hope over experience on a continent
ravaged by the war for centuries and the
vision of the United States at that time
did not end at a strong Europe it was a
global mission while the North Atlantic
Treaty Organization NATO was set up to
safeguard the security of the West the
United Nations aim to foster cooperation
and relation between all countries the
International Monetary Fund sought
financial and monetary stability and the
gut a later WTO the World Trade
Organization was established to create a
stable global environment for global
trade open trade and this approach was
built on two values one idealistic and
one more realistic the first one human
beings we have certain common values
universal values of freedom democracy
open trade rule-based world order second
in global politics powers so this grand
American design so Europe as the second
half of the liberal world order and the
design worked Western Europe stood up as
a bulwark against communism the creation
of the European Community was an
important way to achieve peace and
prosperity after two devastating wars
and after 1991 it anchored democracy as
the obvious choice for those emerging
from behind the Iron Curtain time and
time again on the international stage
Europe and the United States stood
together our alliance was and still is
the envy of the world but now the world
is changing the world is more and more
dominated by new powers
emerging economies our reliance is
increasingly tested this year is the
70th anniversary of the launch of the
Marshall Plan so like I said we need to
refresh our memories we must recall that
the global order as we know it
cannot be taken for granted and we must
approach the challenges of the 21st
centuries with the same level of
ambition as Harry Truman and George
Marshall once did together the US and
the EU are powerful enough to sustain
the liberal world order and of course we
have many partners here and dividing at
this time will only serve to weaken both
of us we need to unite and trade would
be the obvious place to start here it is
one of our fundamental economic freedoms
and perhaps the very corner stone of the
relationship between countries it's
spread wealth and prosperity builds
bonds between states and it also brings
people closer together and nowhere is
this more apparent than the
transatlantic relationship for decades
this relationship has been a central
artery of the world economy it is the
largest and most significant economic
relationship in the world we trade one
trillion US dollars worth of goods and
services every one trillion US dollars
the EU is by far the largest investor in
the u.s. we account for 72% of all
inward foreign direct investment in the
US but at the end of the day what is
important is not these figures it's the
impact on ordinary people 15 million
jobs are supported by the transatlantic
economy let's reflect upon that that's
not just a number these are 15 million
individuals going to work 15 million
people supporting themselves their
families thanks to transatlantic trade
and it goes wider than that what matters
in global trade matters also to local
economies and what matters in
transatlantic trade matters to the world
the eu-us relationship is essential to
the stability of trade flows we are an
example of what we can achieve when we
work side-by-side and we can guarantee
together a future for the multilateral
trading system
recently this system has the stability
between us has been put into question
there has been tough rhetoric linking
trade and security a link that will only
serve to make us both poorer and weaker
there has been talk of trade wars
between countries but an important truth
of trade is that ultimately countries do
not trade companies and people do it is
as simply as this countries either
create a stable environment for trade or
they don't and either way it is the
general public the citizens who will
feel the impact and the pain of every
conflict because the world is
interconnected in an unprecedented way
and in our two continents in particular
trade balance is not like a bank balance
wherever supply chain runs they bring
wealth and job a car can be bought in
Seattle assembled in Detroit having been
designed by a German built with the
Mexican chassis and Canadian engine
parts this is how trade is win-win and
trying to do or undo these links will
hurt our companies our consumers and the
communities built around these
industries it would do untold damage to
our economies and it would damage
friendship and create tensions and we
will do all that precisely at a time
when we should be working on other
issues for instance pressuring China on
their unfair trading practices when it
comes to global global unfair
overcapacity on steel the operation of
state controlled companies or forced
technology transfer during the past
decades we have seen a number of global
challenges rise in the trade area unfair
competition trade distortions failures
in the multilateral system so it is
understandable that the u.s. feels the
need for a decisive response but we are
concerned about the forum that response
has taken blocking appointments
necessary for the dispute settlement
function in the WTO imposing global
trade restrictive measures on steel and
aluminium
trying to justify them on national
security grounds taking unilateral trade
measures against China and using
increasingly aggressive rhetoric at
allies these measures are disruptive to
alliances when we should be coordinating
they work against the global order when
we should be consolidating and they
undermine decades of u.s. foreign policy
and Western partnership we don't want to
escalate that situation but we have had
no choice but to response we are not
prepared to walk away from the order we
have built together and let it fade like
an old memory so we have taken action in
a way that we think is reasonable
proportionate and in accordance with
international rules our response on the
steel and aluminium tariffs has three
parts first we have taken the case to
the WTO illegal moves under the system
need to be challenged through the system
second we have taken step to assert our
rights under WTO rules we must maintain
a balance of rights and obligation
visibly the United States we cannot put
be put at disadvantage because of
unjustified tariff increases that is
fair and reasonable so to do this we
have set of products on which to apply
balancing tariffs on imports from the
United States
but again we respect the WTO rules so
the bulk of this will only apply in
three years time and by then we hope
that this conflict is over third we need
to protect the ear from the spillover
effects of the US tariffs steel and
aluminium redirected from the US could
distort the EU market further
undermining ear producers who are
already facing higher duties in the u.s.
to stop this from happening we are
applying safeguards to prevent any
excess steel from disrupting our markets
and this goes only to show that when you
play with a global trading system
principle it creates an unstable
environment and we regret that glad to
do this but we have to protect ourselves
a large part of protecting yourself is
enforcing trading rules because the
global rulebook is useless
if it's not followed and to be clear we
enforce the rules whenever they are
broken and wherever they
broken the same day we launched the WTO
case against the US we also launched the
case against China on force technology
transfers so we want to defuse this
situation as soon as possible
we need to de-escalate this before it
blows up in our faces
doing harm to the transatlantic
relationship our economies and the
global order George Marshall once said
the only way to win a war is to prevent
it and that goes also for trade wars
there will be no winners we have been
engaging with the u.s. to try to find a
solution
I have almost lost count on my numerous
calls with Secretary of Commerce mr.
Wilbur Ross trying to pursued him that
Europe is not the source of America's
problem in steel and aluminium that did
not work unfortunately and now we are
seriously concerned about the new US
investigation on cars and car parts
under Section two three two motivated
again by national security steel and
aluminium measures turned rhetoric into
reality and doing the same on cars would
create a new grim reality indeed our
steel and aluminium the world is
undeniable facing challenges as a result
of global over capacity the root cause
is China but similar moves on cars would
be disastrous we are talking about much
higher amounts of trade affected you
exports of steel and aluminium subjected
to extra duties of six point four
billion euros that's a lot of money but
EU car and car park exports to the US
are worth more than 50 billion euros
every year and not only this let's also
remember that the US auto sector is
healthy their exports have been rising
consistently over the last decades and
so has foreign investment in u.s. car
manufacturing including from many EU
companies in fact many EU companies are
using the United States as a platform
for exporting to other countries even
back to Europe for instance BM vx5 model
and it is only Magnum fact manufactured
in one place in the entire world and
that South Carolina and the US car
produces didn't ask for this neither did
the unions the car dealers the US
Chamber of Commerce or the Republican
Party and why well because the US car
industry is so closely integrated into
global chain supply chains not only
North America ripping apart those supply
chains would result in less production
less investment and less jobs in the
u.s. so tariff measures on cars are
neither wanted or warranted they are at
best a solution in search of a problem
at worst they are an illegal move to
gain leverage in trade negotiations and
to be clear simply looking at the metric
of trade imbalances doesn't give an
accurate picture of the transatlantic
relationship at all having a gap cannot
be seen as money that would be lost to
other countries the trade balance has
much more to do like things from savings
from the citizens value of one's
currency consumer patterns for instance
one moment in time when the trade
deficit of the United States were
shrinking quickly was during the Great
Recession of 2008 because the purchasing
power of the American consumers were
down but that should not make us here
and back to how our economies looked in
the - in 2008 the bottom line is that
the US makes more money doing business
with the EU than with anybody else we
are the top destination for American
exports we buy hundreds of billions
worth of American goods and services
every year and in transatlantic trade in
services the US has a surplus next week
President jean-claude Juncker and I will
travel to Washington DC we will do so in
the spirit of a longstanding friendship
between the US and Europe we want to try
to find solutions to de-escalate the
present situation prevent it from
worsening we hope that we can find sway
ways of working together and to advance
on a positive mutually beneficial trade
agenda
we want to create additional
opportunities for trade and investment
that would benefit both sides of the
Atlantic and during the quick visit in
DC I will also meet key Senators
Congressmen to discuss with them as well
as representatives from business and the
message is that we are a committed
global trader from the European Union
and as such we're open to ideas about
opening trade we are prepared to think
outside the box and find solution that
suits us both so let's approach this
like the allies allies and the partners
that we are having said this let's not
forget that they are indeed problems in
the international trading system that we
can agree upon however US measures on
steel and aluminium will not solve the
overcapacity problem in China and the
same goes for the use of the so called
section 301 the measures that the US
have taken against China on forced
technology transfer trying to force the
hand of China with illegal action will
not work and the US might end up
breaking the multilateral system our
view is that another approach is needed
we need to come together to reform and
strengthen the WTO and the strategy to
modernize the WTO has three elements in
our view reviving the dispute settlement
mechanism it has served as well it has
served the US well updating the rules to
face the 21st century challenges they do
need updating improving the day-to-day
work of the organization and if we do
this we can deal with the emerging
challenges in rule-based trade and at
the core it's about keeping the system
relevant and effective and let me say a
few words about how we can keep it
relevant we wrote the rulebook in the
WTO over 20 years ago it have served as
well it still does but even as we use it
we must of course update any recent
years we have seen new challenges arise
challenges that the rules were not
equipped to deal with
the first step to what solving this is
opening up negotiations or new topics
such as massive state subsidies to
industry forced technology transfer
barriers for access for investment these
are important issues where we need new
rules the system was set up to deal with
open and transparent traders so we
cannot let countries take advantage of
that we need to fill the gaps we need to
do so while we continue to work on the
traditional issues like subsidies to
illegal fisheries for instance where the
WTO ministers lost here in December in
Buenos Aires were not able to take any
sort of decision to stop subsidies to
illegal fishing global trade does not
stay still it is constantly changing and
if we want to avoid finding yourself in
a point like this again we need to adapt
to these changes and the WTO needs to
adopt that's why we need more
flexibility in the negotiations and the
way negotiations work right now is
fraught time and again we have seen
progress held back by a small number of
countries that pursue narrow selfish
interests and as the WTO functional
consensus we cannot move so this
approach has now shown its limits
members must be free to move forward at
different speeds to integrate and meet
criteria at different times as long as
we are following the existing rules of
the WTO and exploring this option would
allow us to make progress in key areas
and this is not a new idea or a bold
experiment we had tried before it has
worked in the past and we applied it
after the ministerial in Buenos Aires
last year groups of interested countries
have already started to make progress on
e-commerce on domestic regulation in
services in investment facilitation in
all these three areas they are a big
group of member states from the WTO from
all continents rich and poor who come
together because they realize here we
need to do global work and we want this
to be integrated in the WTO system too
is more adaptable while applying
pressures on the more difficult
remembers gathering in groups has been a
path to progress in trade for some time
we recently and host our trilateral
cooperation with Japan and the US and
together we seek to tackle systemic
problems in the global trading system it
gives us a forum to discuss ways to
improve the WTO rulebook and we hope
that it will have other effects too like
showing the u.s. that the partners are
serious about reform and this way we
hope we can build the confidence in the
multilateral system again but of course
update rulebook is half of the work what
we also need to make sure is that the
rulebook is followed so if we want to
ensure that people follow the rules we
need to make sure that WTO is effective
because without enforcement to the rules
or pointers and the first step to do
this obviously is to resolve the crisis
in that plate body the dispute
settlement mechanism of the WTO is vital
and the US needs to stop blocking their
appointment of judges the applet body is
not perfect we are indeed open to reform
the work of this body if we truly want
to tackle all distortions of the trading
system we need a dispute settlement
mechanism to bring order in the global
trading environment and we also need
improvement in the regular work of the
WTO in the committees and the day-to-day
functioning they need to be real rewards
for complying with the rules and they
need to be penalties for those to find
them the organization need to be much
more transparent and reliable it will
not be easy but the world global trade
order is worth saving and there are many
countries out there who believe in this
and want to work with us because this is
the best way to safeguard our joint
long-term interests in global trees
because a strong rule-based approach
stands against protectionism and ensures
a predictable environment for all
businesses and it creates prosperity by
opening markets across the world so we
are not alone here luckily the European
Union in putting our faith in open
global trade
we have look at our recent negotiation
agenda we have closed a trade deal with
Canada it is now working and it has
already shown some benefits Mexico
we concluded earlier this year Japan we
signed yes two days ago in Japan we hope
that it will enter into force by New
Year when the European Parliament has
voted as well Vietnam and Singapore are
closed and today had just come from and
I will go back to negotiations with
medica soon where we're making good
progress we're also making good progress
with Chile and others and we just
recently opened negotiations with
Australia and New Zealand New Zealand
negotiations are going on right now this
week here in Brussels so this is just an
example of the list and these countries
are important for economic partnership
but they're also part of a circle of
friends who share values with us and who
want to work together to strengthen the
global trading system who believes in
the benefits of trade and who believes
in multilateralism so the international
trading system is facing its deepest
crisis since the end of the Second World
War the roots of these crisis are deep
and complex and there are no quick fixes
but our response from the EU is clear at
home we need to make our economy and
society more resilient we need to be
strong to meet the challenges of
globalization by investing in skills for
changing work moving up value chains
through research and innovation and
making sure that our societies are
socially inclusive and business friendly
this is our home work abroad we need to
tackle the causes of international trade
tensions doing away with WTO wouldn't
solve anything it would increase
confrontation we would return to a time
for tit-for-tat
tariffs and trade governed by politics
not by markets we have seen this we had
a taste of it and it doesn't taste good
we firmly believe that our reform plan
can transform multilateral trade and by
modernizing the WTO keeping it relevant
keeping it effective we can get global
rule-based trade back on track the
Marshall Fund
shaped the 20th century by firmly
establishing liberal democracy as the
global order the u.s. achieved this with
Europe as its counterpart across the
water they further shaped this order
with alliances and rule cite in a
setting nato united nation IMF WTO now
we are at a crossroad for open global
trade it is possible that the relative
transatlantic relationship could once
again shape the global orders for the
years to come and my hope is that the US
will join us
in this investment in creating rules for
the good of the global community this is
the only way that we can guarantee
stability in the 21st century and return
to order to global open trade thank you
very much
[Applause]
Commissioner thank you so much for that
you've given us a lot to think about
again in very turbulent times but we
also have the opportunity and you're
very kind to stay with us for a bit of
time to have some some questions and
some answers
so please do catch my eye and do tell us
who you are and where you're from and
for those who are not familiar with this
room the microphones are in the or in
the hand rest actually you don't need to
turn them off so so there it is and
maybe if I could just go right here in
the front first please you do need to
turn them on okay for the work that
you're doing the work that the
Commission is doing to support the rule
of law and the support the rules-based
multilateral free trading system my
question is you mentioned in your speech
that you're gonna be meeting congressmen
and Senators on the hill what is your
sense is the mood changing how is it
changing is it changing fast enough what
are the arguments that you are using
you're deploying with that constituency
to convince them of the logic of your
argument that we are actually natural
partners in a bigger problem thank you
very much nice to see you again and well
I have been regularly meeting of course
with the congressmen in in the United
States as part of of my work and even if
we've had disagreements sometimes on
substance I've always felt that as
European had been welcomed that there is
a natural inclination to to think that
Europe and the United States are friends
and partners and if we work together we
can do a lot of things so the notion
that Europe is a foe is not something
I've ever encountered in
at the hill and I hope not when I come
I'm still working on the shadows I don't
know exactly in what order I will meet
with people but I come there with the
message that we are still strong
believers of the transatlantic
friendship and partnership for
historical reasons but also for for the
future and increasing trade tensions
between us is not the solution it's
going to harm not only that that strong
friendship between us but it is also
going to do a lot of harm to our
economies on both sides it is going to
penalize American jobs and industries as
well and this is not a good thing and
once you start escalating like this is
very hard to step down and instead we
should be working together I mentioned
our own WTO I know that there is a lot
of criticism towards the WTO in the u.s.
some of that criticism is fair let's
let's look at it and try to see how we
can advance together and let's see how
we can work together to address one of
the main concerns in the u.s. is certain
development in China we share those
concerns and we conveyed them at the
last summit with China but we don't
share the methods that the US are
addressing them with so let's see how we
can work together bilaterally but also
in different global forums in t20 in the
global steel forum in other forums how
to address these issues and let's not
impose tariffs likely to each other for
for strange reasons because they caused
a lot of harm and damage that are very
very difficult to repair afterwards so
we come there you know to try to see how
can we work together can we increase our
trade you know that we had discussions
on the free-trade agreement with the US
for for a long time now that particular
TTP TTIP you even forgot the name was
and is not on the table anymore but it's
anything else we can do to facilitate
trade that would be the way to do to
address it so let's see this will be one
occasion to meet them it is not the
first sign is certainly not the last so
I will continue to have dialogue with
represent elected representatives with
business communities we see the society
in the u.s. because the US has a lot of
stakeholders and I think it's important
to talk to all of them
you know speaking of TTIP I recall we
had in this room an extrordinary
discussion with Mike Froman at one time
and it seems like a lost Golden Age or
something but anyway that wasn't an easy
discussion either it but there it was if
I could go just on the aisle right well
the near aisle I think it's one seated
yes please
it should be they turn they tell us they
turn it on so now I think how much in
thank you very much indeed shia islam
from friends of europe commissioner
thank you very much for a very very
important speech and I think you've laid
out some of the biggest challenges
Europe faces today I want to take you up
on the reform of the WTO that you've
talked about very important and you know
about time we did that but I think
you'll agree with me commissioner that
you cannot do it even if the US were to
come back in a more constructive mood
you cannot do it just with the US times
have changed so I was just wondering who
would you turn to you talked about the
like-minded countries but you haven't
talked about India or China as part of
this like-minded group and you cannot
get things done in the WTO without these
two countries on board so I was just
wondering what are your plans how will
you play out in in the coming days
because this reform is crucial as you've
said yourself thank you
no I fully agree with you if you just
hang around with like-minded you get a
nice and comfortable view of the world
but that is not going to change it so of
course we discussed with like-minded
that group is quite big I was recently
in Geneva there is a sort of informal
group there called the friends of the
system which consists of 50 55 countries
from all over big and small and also
countries with whom we don't normally
engage on these issues because they've
truly believed in the WTO system and we
discussed there with them and we you
know try to exchange some views and
everybody's doing some thinking as well
there are regular meetings also with on
different levels on this as I said we
just came back from China at a you China
summit and the Chinese have agreed to
set up a working group with us on
reforming the WTO and this has been
agreed on the highest level and we will
discuss the parameters of this and I
mean everything is on the table we have
said that we want to discuss the reform
of the rules and some of these rules do
concern China but is also in their
interests that we talk talk about them
together but also some of the issues
that I mentioned they might have other
concerns that they want to discuss so I
mean we
made up the agenda yet we just decided
so that would be a very important
platform to test some ideas and to see
how far we can come then the WTO
countries regularly meet of course to
discuss these issues in divorce and then
the ministerial Xin in the framework of
of OECD meetings and so on so we need to
continue to talk to to everybody on this
on on India we haven't reached out
specifically they hosted an event I
think almost a year ago on on WTO to
have first discussions are on reform
they were not conclusive but at least I
think that they they are engaging as
well so we need to find ways to look at
them as well because in India of course
is one of the countries who have a lot
of problems with the WTO and sometimes
we we have a problems with their
problems but they need to be on board of
course because they are the key to
unlock some of the old doha issues
development and so on and we absolutely
need to have India and other countries
on board to see how we can unblock the
situation and move forward over there by
the door if you can if we can get you to
a microphone that way the Commission you
mentioned the out-of-the-box solutions
where the United States is plurilateral
car-deer something that you could think
that could work in your discussions also
with other partners like China like
South Korea Japan that would need to be
on board could this possibly work or
should we unilaterally a lower the car
tariffs or something to appease the girl
United States and just on the good
progress with Marcos or if you allow I
think it's a long shot to to expect that
the talks would wrap up today but do you
think it could possibly be done before
the summer break or they preserve the
elections or I'll be looking more
something towards the end of the year or
even later thank you thank you on this
plurilateral idea that is circulating
around the world this is one of the of
many and for it to work you would have
to to
clewd the mass of the big car produces
would have to agree on that I don't know
if they do maybe it's worth exploring
but it's not sort of a solution the the
agenda we come with to President Trump
it is one idea of many I don't know if
it is going if it would work at all so
let's see just bilateral taking away car
terrace between the EU and the US well
it will have to be broader but of course
because this you cannot do because these
are based on on most favored nation
bases so if you don't include it in a
broader trade agreement you will have to
do it for the rest of the world and I
don't think that the big car producing
countries in this world will you know
unilaterally do this because we'd have a
lot of free riders across the world and
it would also damage the work we have
done in some of our bilateral trade
agreements with important partners so
thinking outside the box yes we are
thinking and if you have any ideas
you're welcome back but there's not not
sort of this is the solution we propose
I think the aim of resident Yonkers
visit is to try to establish a good
relation try to see how we can
deescalate the situation avoiding it
from from going going further and see if
there is a forum where we can discuss
these issues I mean I think the the time
is it's very short so we're not expected
to solve all the solutions and there's a
lot of things that the White House want
to discuss as well but hopefully a good
first meeting that that could lead to
something on a longer process on the
macro sewer while we spent the whole day
yesterday the ministers are in town and
started very early this morning and I
will leave you to go back on this we are
making good progress
we are absolutely attacking some of the
very difficult questions there's still a
long list to deliver so it's not like we
would have called for a press conference
at four o'clock and declare that we're
done but but maybe five but but I hope
that we can make a lot of good progress
and by the end of the day we will
outcome with the ministers the way
forward we are very close but I don't
want to give you a date because I did
that before that was wrong just on the
other side just on the oil yes red
jacket please
hello commissioner mobster my name is
Amy Paul from Durham television zdf I
have question concerning the recent
steel messer measures by the u SD u
escalating the trade war with the US by
imposing new EU safeguards on steel
thank you yes we we just decided to have
provisional safeguards on some of our
steel industry this is based on an
investigation that started in March so
we have provisional results from that
but the investigation will continue
until the end of the year where we will
decide whether to make them permanent or
not these safeguards are based on
historical flows so it's CR cues for
those who are familiar with that so we
hope that they will not distort the
traditional trade and and sort of impose
new restrictions but protect our steel
companies from the steel that was
intended for the US and is now now
coming and and distorting the markets
you are entitled to do so according to
the WTO we have followed all the rules
here they are provisional entry to force
I think the 18th of July and I don't
think they are there Iger allness so
it's all countries but they are based on
on traditional flows so in order to
minimize the the damaging the
protectionism of this and this we we
have to do it's it's a response to
protect our industry from something that
we think it is it is deeply unfair I'm
conscious of your time but perhaps we
take two more and we're okay okay good
please thank you very much hello Jana
dryer from border Lakes
and Commissioner Momsen what if the
meeting goes through and what's a plan B
should things go
not very well with the United States in
the coming days and weeks or even more
retaliation I mean Candice Candice
continued to escalate or not what about
the WTO if if the blockage continues is
there a plan to work make it work
despite the US
what's what's the thinking on you know
the worst case scenario where where does
the Commission want to want to take you
know the edu on board because the work
that has been proposed is very
constructive but it's a long-term
endeavor but what happens if things
really go wrong thank you well I don't
want to speculate about this this
meeting it's a meeting between two two
leaders they meet and they discuss they
have met many times before so they're
not new to each other we've known from
the past that these meetings can be a
bit unpredictable but but we come there
with with the best intentions and as
friends and allies and with the true
willingness to start a dialogue on how
we can deescalate this situation and to
express our concerns about a possible
decision to impose car to car in car
parts tariffs that is are now under
investigation then we will see what
comes out of that meeting that is
certainly only beginning of hopefully a
process where we couldn't continue to
discuss me and my colleagues we have
lots of contacts also with other members
of the American administration and
government sir so discussions are there
on the the if this would escalate if the
US would impose these characters that
would be very unfortunate but we are
preparing together with our member
states a list of rebalancing measures
there as well and this we have made
clear to our American partners and we
will continue to make that clear that
list is still under preparation but but
it is done in the same way as with the
with the steel and aluminium the
discussions on how to reform the WTO so
they go on we have a working group with
us char Mike from his successor
ambassador delight Heiser and the the
the minister from from Japan or for
industry and trade minister Seco that
goes on and that is constructive we are
making progress there the discussion
that we have with other partners on how
to reform the WTO we are working on on
some papers that we will share with
member states and shortly so that we can
go out and have a more systemic
systematic outreach to others and that
that will continue of course we want the
US
to be on board in that work and that is
also a message that we will convey but
but you know the rest of us are
determined enough to save this system
and that work will continue okay thank
you perhaps are there a lot of hands
we're obviously not going to get to all
of you but two more I'll maybe we take
two together so yes please agnostic one
of them's a lengthy Business Council by
a kind of natural geometry the more
there's tensions with the United States
the more it looks that we need partners
in China and in the fact that you is
working with China at least at the WTO
another area so what are your red lines
because we do know that China of course
is very interested in engaging as much
as possible with EU so you know you fill
in between in a way geographically in
between China and the United States you
cannot at the same time do you does have
of course its own conflicts with China
how how do you position yourself and how
much what are your red lines in terms of
engaging with China thank you and I
think just yes if you can get to a
microphone
maybe someone right in front of you will
lend you will lend you one or or speak
loudly thank you very much Josephine sky
mBLAQ's
commissioner obviously you are
consulting with the Member States on
your visits to Washington what room of
maneuver do you have what sort of Monday
did you get from the member states
regarding what you want to achieve in
Washington are you ready to open proper
negotiations next week or it's going to
be just an introduction to this thank
you thank you please just right here
thank you I'm repping Caritas eternal on
the both on the trilateral you're now
engaged in the scoping exercises I'm
curious as to what you hope to achieve
in the working group with China and how
confident are you in China's engagement
for WTO reform it's a real effort will
the EU play a bridge role between the
trilateral with the US and Japan on one
hand other partners on the other and
China on yet another and or is this just
a effort by China to try and take some
heat off and counterbalance and find
some allies to stand side-by-side as it
comes under attack from from tariffs
thank you also the China question
jointly the European Union is not taking
sides between the US and China we have
some concerns and I think I was very
clear about the u.s. latest measures and
the the tensions in our relations but we
equally have new and old concerns with
China we as I said we took them to the
WTO on the transfer of technology that
we don't agree with we do not agree with
that we know that they have made some
progress on on over capacity but there's
far from enough they need to do much
more they are concerns on cyber theft
and others and that we have concerned I
conveyed to to China together with all
our traditional concerns that we have
the massive state subsidies the the
problems that our companies have to act
on an equal basis on the Chinese market
human right concerns we always convey
but we do also have an interest of
course in try to deepen our relations
with China we have since a long time now
been talking about an investment
agreement for the first time we exchange
offers that
of progress we are now analyzing this
office because quite thick papers we
receive just a couple of days ago but
that is a move forward and the the
purpose of the investment agreement is
to create a more level playing field for
our companies that they they really they
really want China announcing that they
wanted to be part that they wanted to
work with us on WTO I think it's a
positive step that should be welcomed we
see well I mean it was just only
announced we will have to look at the
the outcome of this I think China is is
really honest in its wish to preserve
and strengthen WTO it doesn't always
follow the WTO rules but as a rule I
would say that they try to be
constructive in in WTO and I think it is
in their interest in the true interest
to have a functioning WTO where they can
work where they can be a part and if
they want to work with us to reform and
update some of the rules that will
concern them I think that that is
absolutely something to exploit and we
were willing to try we'll need to
succeed I don't know but it's always
worth a try and on and that I think it
partly answered
ignacio's question I mean we are
engaging with China as we have always
done now we see that there is an
increased concern in China also over the
future of the of the global trading
system WTO and what what the US are
doing to them I have said that that we
share the u.s. concerns on China we
don't share the methods that they are
addressing them on 301 for instance and
on steel neither but the root causes of
some of the problems of on the traitor
system are to be found in China and
there we need to work with others and
with China to try to reform them on the
the White House visit China where are
you and the White House was it we don't
go there to negotiate anything to
negotiate we need a mandate we don't
have a mandate to negotiate anything
because we don't know what we would
potentially negotiate as I said the
resident goes there with an open mind to
establish hopefully and or to build on
on relationship that is already there
and see if there is a way that we can
engage that hopeful result of our talk
will then have
to be brought back to member states if
there is any mandates needed but at
least to start talking to try to see if
we can deescalate the situation to see
if there is a way that we can start
talking about facilitating trade between
us without the threat of tariffs that
would be a good outcome then if that
needs a mandate then of course as always
member states need to be to be consulted
and give their their consent on that we
keep very close contact with all the
Member States on this I think as late as
yesterday night there was a core apero
meeting where where the ambassadors were
were debriefed on on the latest of the
meeting and there will be debrief the
day after as well when we come home so
there is absolutely no no conflict there
and to go and talk and to see I think
everybody appreciates that it's it's you
know it's an effort we should try to do
but we'll see maybe there would be no
outcome at all and then we will have to
discuss what what to do not in Krishna
thank you very much indeed
thank you for being with us thank you
for your remarks thank you for dealing
with the questions in such an open and
frank way please join me in thanking
we hope to have you with us again soon
we hope have all of you with us again
soon thank you for being with us here we
wish you a very good summer
we wish you a very good trip and we look
forward to continuing the conversation
thank you so much thank you for
organizing this thank you to our hosts
thank you for organizing this thank you
to all of you for being here and I think
we can say to be continued
[Laughter]
[Music]